en estas cuatro semanas adicionales para
la reapertura total del país que se
espera entonces sede el 19 de julio el
gobierno confía en que todos los adultos
sobre los 18 años habrán recibido para
esa fecha por lo menos una dosis contra
el hobbit 19 y cientos más habrán
completado el esquema total de las
vacunas y es que los casos aquí en
inglaterra están disparados
especialmente entre los jóvenes y la
variante delta encontrada por primera
vez en la india es la dominante de esta
variante en una semana los casos han
aumentado hasta en un 64% los asesores
científicos del gobierno prevén
consideraban que si el país se abría
completamente como estaba previsto para
el 21 de junio entonces esa carrera del
cob y de las vacunas no hubiera ganado
el virus por supuesto el sector de la
hospitalidad es el más afectado con esta
extensión para lo que se considera aquí
recuperar la libertad el público también
está dividido
entre quienes aseguran que la prudencia
es la clave para ganar la batalla contra
el cob y 19 y entre quienes quieren que
la normalidad pronto regrese a este país